hallo mein name ist luca und ich kann
nicht sehen deswegen kam ich auf die
wundervolle idee heute ein singspiel zu
spielen
diese spieler ist karaoke resort hat ein
wundervolles kleines mädchen hier wir
ändern einfach mal die sprache auf
deutsch dann lassen wir es einfach auch
brasilianische mein gott das bin ich das
bin ich kein mangel sondern richtig
hässlich wir machen halt hautfarbe
kommen machen gelb hautfarbe damals
haare
warum guckt ihr meine videos ich bin ein
spaß
die haare sind wundervoll dann nehmen
wir als gleich noch ein tolles dazu oder
würde wir nehmen das 9,5 teils gleich
als augen nehmen wir das nehmen wir
ich habe kapital ist immer kommen das
sind jetzt einfach wir jetzt machen wir
mal hier tanken kann man hier tanzen
was mache ich hier gerade passiert mir
das eine cd und ich müsste jetzt
wirklich singen chance was ihm trotz des
namens ist das für ein spiel die musik
ist ganz klar ja ganz schön hier auf mit
dem rumspringen schwieriger
wie lange geht das legt dennoch das
video sondern mischung auf japanisch und
englisch glaube ich
oder es ist eben eine komplett andere
strafe kommt jemand rückt das ist
scheiße
hallo hallo hallo minimal die liebsten
wäre ich gerade getanzt habe weil jetzt
weiß ich schon genau wie man das singen
muss da gerade distanzen habe ich genau
er gehört wie die frau das bewundert das
heißt ich kann das nicht perfekt
familienkarten
bild michael kaiser
for me do
julia das ist scheiße
so hatte ich schon mal ein wort grün und
nicht rot
null da bist einen neuen song my life
von popcorn meine damen und herren ich
strenge mich diesmal in shisha bar
shanghai
ich weiß jetzt warum leute sich aufregen
darüber dass youtube mit seinen scheiß
geld verdient
denn ich bin sicher dass das was ich am
besten kann im leben
und das kann mir keiner mehr nehmen
kippt das nächste videos von rod girl on
heißt follow my heart das ist ein track
der geht echt vom herzen freunde ich
habe gerade beim boosten sterne bekommen
da muss ich noch mal kurz zu machen die
funky dollar collex-bossy 2 i
die nachfolge von jacques sanche was
mache ich hier ich habe ehrlich gesagt
ein bisschen angst dass ich zudem wehrte
nach diesem video deswegen bei endlich
passiert